[ __ ] was there ever any riots when you
were locked up i've been i've been in
two rides
how crazy does that get it's real
yeah that [ __ ] real bro i ain't gonna
lie is was it race related was it it was
some race right [ __ ] so what was that
was it blacks first mexicans oh [ __ ]
that's wild
cracking man so if that [ __ ] pops off
like what did do most people stay out of
the way a lot of people
they tuck their tail bro like you can
see a lot of [ __ ] they tell you like
[ __ ] help me i'm like you know what i'm
saying afterwards in the hole when
everybody in the hole together
you screaming out nigga's name like whoa
dude he didn't do nothing i seen that
[ __ ] hiding over there in the corner
he's just looking at me like you ain't
gonna forget that but uh
but but but something you gonna see what
a [ __ ] made of when that happened when
i in that moment you're gonna you're
gonna see what you made uh so in like
cause because um
how many so in southern california
obviously there's the south siders the
mexicans
do you guys click up with in in jail
race wise or is it just black
celebrities it's just blacks
do the mexicans well we [ __ ] with the
others like um the others the others
like the asians and the uh okay and the
simones and those those are called
asians so the others are just kind of
like there's not enough people
sometimes the others just like maybe
someone from india yeah they're the
others these other yeah yeah like you
know um anything of that ethnicity
japanese chinese so it's the blacks and
the others yeah the others they fall
under the black and is it
who what about the white the white
supremacists
they're wrong with the mexicans damn
yeah that's f who's the most powerful in
prison
numbers-wise
um it depends on what what yards you
land on
you do like i was i was in a i was in
delano a yard it's a three-yard it was
dominantly black
it was a dominant black yard but then
you know the mexicans they always did
that is true they always
california they always got numbers so
ultimately you'd be them
but it'd be some some some yards where
like because out in az it's it's pretty
much like the aryan nation and then the
mexicans yeah and then
there's not that many black people in
arizona yeah i mean so yeah the aryan
nation and then the mexican mafia
i don't think they're friends from what
i understand
yeah the woods
don't play
they don't play a lot of words too
they don't play yeah they run their own
program for sure but they're going
they're going you should about pecker
woods right the woods the whites the
white people the white yeah
they called woods yeah the pekka was the
woods you know what i'm saying he wrote
wood but uh they they do their own thing
but like in the county it don't be that
many woods they immediately
run with the maskings you know what i'm
saying immediately but at the end of the
day that's who like when it's time to
pick a side that's gonna be together and
this is gonna be it together what if
it's like a okay let me ask you this
right because there's like certain
people we know that are white
who
[ __ ] our [ __ ] or they yeah okay one of
those guys gets arrested that was that
was the first ride i've been in because
it's some [ __ ] like that so do they go
with y'all or do they go with the race
they come they come if they come with us
the race is going to press them the
white boy is going to press up this if
they tripping you like like this what
happened
a white blood came to the door
and i [ __ ] he was a straight white boy
carrot top
and the woods walked up to him trying to
introduce himself and you know show them
the program he was like what i'm gonna
know
he like i'm i'm a gang member i'm from
he was a blood he would you whoop and it
was like what
that the uh the rep for the woods he
wasn't having that he was tripping so he
came to our rep like i'll get him out of
here or
it's going up
so when you say get him out of here they
like like they they like y'all going he
got to go or he's going up
and did it go up it went up oh
over over a white guy who wanted it
because he's running without he running
with the black so we're gonna stand by
him which is a crate which is like very
uh rare
uh
it's not rare what about him what was it
ever been a mexican blood or a mexican
crypt yeah
does that get does that oh there he's
right there
allegedly allegedly
allegedly
but yeah we have one here in the studio
so if he hits the yard he hit the yard
okay so he hits the yard and i was
winning
he's with y'all what else
so if they not trevor in the match
don't give a [ __ ] don't be trippy white
people are on that wise prize